by the way let me help you guys
understand something because sometimes
people don't the Gazelle intensity where
your arm beans and runs rice and beans
where you do not have a life you do not
go on vacation you do not do anything
until you get out of debt and you finish
baby step three when you have your
emergency fund in place and you're
debt-free except your home that's when
you lighten up a notch you let the foot
off the gas a little bit and we start to
live if you're that's when you save up
and go on a vacation or you save up and
pay for a couch or you save up and move
up and home or you save up and pay cash
for a little better car because you're
driving a hoopty or whatever and
hopefully you can do that while you're
saving 15% towards retirement if you
can't then you knock a couple of those
little things out to get your lifestyle
back up to a reasonable level and then
you read then you start baby steps for
because baby Step four or five and six
which is 15% of your income going into
retirement and you know baby step five
is kids college and six is paying off
your home early those are done you know
over a period of years you know and it's
part of your overall goal so here's the
thing I read this thing somebody tweeted
me earlier today it's lady said I quit
doing Dave Ramsey and so I could save my
marriage and when I read the article it
was like you know she was till to sell
intense and trying to pay off her house
and her husband hated her and hated me
and everything else because they were
still you know they're still just living
on beans and rice five six seven years
later and that is not what we teach and
so you can't say you quit doing Dave
Ramsey because honey you weren't doing
Dave Ramsey you weren't doing what we
teach and you did what you wanted to do
and you blame me for it but that's not
what we teach we don't teach people to
do that and nor what I teach you to do
something to end your marriage let's
just absolutely drama-queen stuff you've
never heard that here on the air I tell
people to do things
keep their marriage together so but your
level of if you go into hyper drama mode
for a decade like that and your spouse
is not on board That's not me giving you
marriage problems that's you giving you
marriage problems you know that's what
we teach so baby steps 1 2 & 3 are with
great focused intensity extreme levels
of sacrifice and even then your spouse
needs to be on board because it's not
going to work you're just going to make
everybody mad around when you try to
force this stuff upon them but when it
is a shared goal we're sacrificing the
win we're going to live like no one else
so later we can live and give like no
one else then when you break through
baby step three you have your emergency
fund in place you don't have anything
that's put a house payment that puts you
in a place to be able to save and invest
and be able to do some lifestyle things
and be able to increase your giving and
get yourself in a rhythm that is much
more reasonable long term and still be
able to hit the goals it still happens
and you still have to be focused you
start to be a grown up but I'm amazed
the number of things I get blamed for
that I didn't do this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]